-[scoffs]
-[DJ] All right, who's up next?
Padge Sawyer!
-Guess it's my turn. Wish me luck.
-[crowd cheers]
[DJ] All right,
nowhere to go but up from there.
-We gotta see this.
-["Teenage Dream" playing]
-♪ We can dance ♪
-[crowd claps, cheers]
♪ Until we die ♪
♪ You and I♪
♪ We'll be young forever♪
♪ You make me♪
♪ Feel like I'm livin' a ♪
♪ Teenage dream ♪
♪ The way you turn me on… ♪
Wow. I don't even know why
she bothers with college.
She might as well just get
her residency in Vegas, am I right?
♪ Don't ever look back ♪
♪ My heart stops♪
♪ When you look at me… ♪
Oh my God.
What?
You're enjoying this?
You're enjoying her.
What? No, I'm not.
No, I'm not. I'm--
-[girl] Oh my gosh, that's Jordan.
-Are you serious?
What? I invited him.
I didn't think he'd show up with her.
[Jordan] Hey!
♪ Got a motel
And built a fort out of sheets ♪
-♪ I finally found you♪
-[girl] Who's that girl?
[singing out of tune]
♪ Missing puzzle piece ♪
♪ I'm complete… ♪
[Cameron] What's going on?
Jordan's her ex. He totally humiliated her
in front of a zillion people.
♪ Just, uh…♪
Oh my gosh. She's dying up there.
Wait. Kweller.
I really don't think you should go!
Kweller, this is a truly awful idea!
♪ You make me♪
♪ Feel like I'm living a ♪
♪ Teenage dream♪
All right, Kweller.
-[crowd cheers]
-♪ I can't sleep♪
♪ Let's runaway
And don't ever look back♪
♪ Don't ever look…♪
-That's the bet guy?
-Yeah.
Who is this dude?
♪ When you look at me ♪
♪ Just one touch♪
♪ Now, baby
I believe this is real ♪
♪ So take a chance and don't… ♪
They're actually kinda good.
♪ Don't ever look
I'mma get your heart racing♪
♪ In my skin-tight jeans ♪
♪ Be your teenage dream tonight♪
[crowd claps, cheers loudly]